[Music]
check it out big celebrity news it's
being
it's being reported that snooki is
pregnant
have you heard this
yeah
yeah yeah when rick santorum heard the
news he immediately came out in favor of
birth control
more than the joke i prefer i like the
audience's reaction to snooki is
pregnant
this is
i didn't say a monster's loose
well yeah but i mean in nine or ten
months
eventually
seriously it has been reported that
snooki is three months pregnant
yeah
doctors say the young life form swimming
in fluids with only minor brain
development is going to have a very
healthy baby
[Applause]
i get how it lines up swimming in fluids
yeah i see don't bring out that part oh
come on that's the best part hey that
was some uh primary last night a gang
it's that or snooky man we gotta talk
about something
we prefer snooki
mitt romney won a squeaker in michigan
last night and uh today in a suburb of
detroit mitt romney asked supporters to
donate money to his campaign
yeah of course then the people pointed
out that they live in detroit and he's
mitt romney
i wonder how that went over yeah
you fellow's mind right
here in the rust belt uh rick santorum
did not do well with women last night
some say that hurt him yeah
i mean in the votes
i didn't do well with women last night
either
please
oh doesn't make sense um
no rick santorum he's having trouble
connecting with women voters in a speech
last night rick santorum tried to repair
his image with female voters
yeah although it didn't help that the
speech started out with listen up
[ __ ]
shocking story i couldn't believe this a
new report says that an increasing
number of medical students are paying
off their med school loans with
prostitution
yeah
which explains why during my last
physical my doctor was also naked
thank you
nicely done he examined me and i
examined him
what is that i don't know
what was that
i just did that and i don't know if i
should have all right either that or
it's my new thing and it's gonna sweep
the nation yeah yeah
[Music]
there's a guy up there doing it and it
looks
weird when you sit
down
don't don't do it i'll say wing
i swear to god if someone's going to
come to me in the street the next couple
days ago hey conan huh
and i'm going to have forgot right what
they're talking about looks like you're
starting a push mower yeah kind of it
doesn't have that kind of feel to it
you'll see it's going to be big with
kids
kids love mowing yeah
stupid kids
scientists are looking into the world's
oldest murder case a man who was
murdered 5 000 years ago
yeah larry king immediately came forward
with an alibi
[Applause]
any fans of musicals here oh
i'll leave that alone they've begun
casting a broadway musical about tupac
shakur
that's true
no surprises so far uh matthew
broderick's tupac nathan lane is biggie
smalls so
look forward to that
getting picky s'mores yeah
riya
big news folks tomorrow justin bieber
turns 18.
he has a big relief for me because
starting tomorrow my justin bieber
backpack and matching lunch box doesn't
seem so creepy anymore does it
walk around
[Applause]